[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في
برنامجكم الشارع الدبلوماسيه الذين تناوله
من خلاله في هذه الحلقه الثانيه
الذي اختاره رئيس الجمعيه العامه
من رئيسين المفاوضات الحكوميه الدوليه
توافقيه لاصلاح مجلس الامن
المناقشه الملف الحيويه لمبادره البحر
الاسود للحبوب الغذائيه
الامين العام لمنظمه المؤتمر الامم
المتحده لتجاره والتنميه الدوليه
والراعيه الامميه لهذه المبادره وقاده
المفاوضات مع روسيا مؤخرا عندما علقت
موسكو التطبيق
جريزمان نجحت في الثامن عشر من نوفمبر
اقناعي روسيا باستئناف التطبيقي لهذه
الاتفاق الاساسي
وخاصه الدول الفقيره والناميه في عالميه
[موسيقى]
مشاجره الكرام بعد مرور 77 عاما على تاسيس
الامم المتحده يتفق الجميع على اهميه
اجراء اصلاحات على هيكله وقواعد عملها
وذلك بهدف مواكبتي متطلبات القرن الحادي
والعشرين وضماني مصداقيتها امام الشعوب
العالم
مجلس الامن الدولي المكلف بحفظ الامن
والسلم الدوليين يعتبر من اهم الكائنات
هذه المنظمه الدوليه واثبت اجراء
الاصلاحات عليه كونه امر صعب
ويسجن الان ان نستضيف منجوبه الكويت
الدائم السفير طارق البناي المكلف مع
سفيري جمهوريه اسلوباكيا بقياده دفه
المفاوضات الحكوميه الدوليه التي تبدا في
يناير القادم عبر الاثير من المنتدى
التاسع للتحالف الحضارات المقام هذا العام
في مدينه فاس المغربيه
وذلك في اول لقاء صحفي له منذ تعيينه في
منصبه الحالي في شهر اغسطس الماضي
[موسيقى]
السفير طارق البنائي مندوب الكويت الدائم
لدى الامم المتحده اهلا وسهلا بك على شاشه
العربيه
اهلا وسهلا
دائما الكويت لدى الامم المتحده ان دوله
الكويت لن تنسى ابدا واقتبس ما قلته لن
تنسى ابدا دور الامم المتحده ومجلس الامن
في عمليه تحرير الكويت بدء بالقرار
التاريخي
660 الذي صدر في ثاني من اغسطس عام
ووصولا الى عوده الشرعيه وتحرير البلاد
مؤكدا على اهميه هذه المنظمه الدوليه
كمحفل الرئيسي معني بتعذيذه اسس واحكام
القانون الدولي والقانون الانساني الدولي
ما هو شعورك اليوم بعد انتخابكم واسلوباك
ايضا لرئاسه مشتركه للمفاوضات الحكوميه
الدوليه لاصلاح المجلس الامن وهو اهم في
هذه المنظمه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بالفعل يا اخ طلال الامم المتحده
ودوله الكويت لهم تاريخ متشابك منذ العام
ونحن اا نؤكد في كل مناسبه على اهميه
العمل متعدده الاطراف وعلى اهميه الدور
الذي يقوم به مجلس الامن كالجه الرئيسيه
المخوله
بموجب ميثاق الامم المتحده لحفظ الامن
والسلم الدولي
في الحقيقه هو فخر كبير لشخصين ان ان يتم
تكليفه من رئيس الجمعيه العامه مع زميلي
الاخ ميكال ملر من السلوفاكيا لان نكون
رؤساء مشتركين لهذه العمليه طبعا هذه
العمليه ليست همم جديده اعتقد انه مساله
اصلاح مجلس الامن همم كانت فكره تراود همم
الدول الاعضاء منذ بسيطه من انشاء المنظمه
من 1945 اااه ونحن كدوله صغيره ودوله مرت
بتجربه عصيبه ااه وكان لهذه المؤسسه
الدور المحوري في تحرير البلاد اا نؤمن
بها
ونؤمن باهميته ونؤمن باهميه مجلس الامن
كالادات القانونيه الوحيده المخوله
بالقيام
عندما يقول خبراء ومراقبون الامم المتحده
انهم يريدون اصلاح مجلس الامن ماذا يعنون
بالتحديد مساله الاصلاح اللي احنا اللي
احنا قائمين عليها الان همم مساله بدات من
2008 بموجب مقرر من
الجمعيه العامه يبدا هذه العمليه مكلفه
بالنظر في خمسه محاور رئيسيه الخمسه
المحاور هي فئه المقاعد
مساله حق النقض الفيتو التمثيل الاقليمي
حجم مجلس الامن واساليب عمله والعلاقه بين
مجلس الامن والجمعيه العامه ستواجهون
تحديات صعبه في هذه المفاوضات الحكوميه
الدوليه ولا شك
من اجل التوصل الى توافق دولي
البعض يصف هذه المفاوضات الحكوميه الدوليه
بانها مهمه شبه مستحيله
ولكن هل من الممكن ان تشاركنا هنا
بخطه بخطه معينه لديكم انت وسفير سلوفاكيا
الاستئناف هذه المفاوضات في يناير وهل
تركت قطر والدنمارك الرئيستان السابقتان
للمفاوضات هذه
للكويت والسلوفيا
للانطلاق منها يعني هل جرى هناك
اي همم تقدم خلال هذه 14 سنه الماضيه
اشكرك بانك وصفتها بالمهمه همم
المستحيله مش الان
لان بالفعل اللي اللي يشوف العمليه
التفاوضيه من 14 سنه ما قدرنا نوصل الى
شيء ملموس الى حد الان يعني لا يقدر انه
يقول الا هالكلام
واود يعني في هذه المناسبه واشكرك على على
تطرقه الى دوله قطر الشقيقه
والدنمارك لان بالفعل كان دورهم جدا همم
مميز همم
واستطاعوا ابتكار بعض الممارسات الجديده
اللي انا وزميلي نتدارس الان تطبيقها همم
خلال الدوره القادمه طبعا ال- ال- الحوار
اللي تم على مدى ثلاث ايام في الامم
المتحده في الجمعيه العامه اتاح لنا
الفرصه بان نستمع همم
ونحاول ان نرى همم ما هي نقاط التقاء ما
بين الدول وما هي المساحات التي ستمكن من
من همم دفع هذه العمليه الى الامر همم
ونحن الان في طور الاعداد لبرنامج همم
الثانوي القادمه طلب منا من قبل رئيس
الجمعيه العامه اللي احب اقول لك انه جدا
مهتم بعمليه اصلاح مجلس الامن وليس هو فقط
طبعا يعني اذا اذا اذا
حللنا كلمات الدول خلال همم الجزء رفيع
المستوى من الدوره 77 لانه 73 رئيس دوله
وحكومه تطرق الى مساله الاصلاح ابو اصلاح
مجلس الامن تحديدا وهذا ما يعني ان بقيه
الدول اااه هذا الموضوع ليس في سلم
اولاوياتها ولكن
خصصه من الوقت الثمين الذي تح لهم همم
امام همم العالم والجمعيه العامه وتطرق
الى هذا الموضوع بس رئيس
كلمه همم الرئيس جو بايدن كانت جدا مهمه
وتبشر بالخير همم احد همم
الدول دائمه العضويه اللي كان لها موقف
يعني خنقول مبهم في السابق الان اصبحت
تدفع بمساله الاصلاح وهذا امر طيب همم
وجيد ويحفزنا نحن كذلك ليس فقط لان
الولايات المتحده الوحيده التي تكلمت على
هالموضوع ولكن 73 رئيس دوله تكلم على هذا
الموضوع وفي الوثيقه الصادره عن الذكر 75
للامم المتحده لتفقد عليها كافه الدول
العالم وكافه رؤساء الدول العالم
على اهميه مساله الاصلاح وضروره الدفع بها
الى الامام
وللامانه اا يعني يصعب علينا ان ان نرى
باننا سننتظر 14 سنه القادمه عشان نحقق
شيء ملموس في هذا المجال فان شاء الله
يعني همم تماما ان انا وزميلي مايك مايكل
همم يعني راح نبدل كل ما فينا لان لان
نحاول ولو ولو شئ بسيط ولكن يحاول ان نضع
اسس يمكن الانطلاق منها الى عمليه حقيقيه
فعليه نظره نتائجها في القريب العادي
السفير طارق البرنامج الدائم لدى الامم
المتحده نشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات وعلى
خصك العربيه بهذه المقابله الاولى لك في
منصبك الجديد اتمنى لك كل التوفيق ونتمنى
لجهودك النجاح في سبيل اصلاح مجلس الامن
همم وان كانت المهمه فعلا مهمه مستحيله
شكرا لك
اشكرك من القلب استاذ طلال يعني انا
يسعدني جدا انك تكون هذه اول مقابله مع
اعلامي قدير مخضرم مثلكم امم
يعني لا نستغني عن الرقابه الاعلاميه حتى
في هذه المساله الضروريه همم لان
مساله الاصلاح
اصبحت اليوم همم
جوهريه
وما لنا غنى عنها ابدا
الكرام اصبح الملايين من شعوب
العالميه يعتمدون في قوتهم اليوميه على
استمراريه عملي مبادره البحر الاسود
للحبوب الغذائيه التي سنتناولها بالتفصيل
مع النفس اسئله الاموميه الرعايه لها ربك
ادريس ولكن بعد فاصلين اعلانيه قصير فلا
تذهبوا بعيدا
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم ثانيه
يسرون الان ان نستضيف حصريا ربك
الامين العام لمنظمه المؤتمر الامم
المتحده لتجاره والتنميه الدوليه وهي في
نفس الوقت
المسؤوله الامميه عن مبادره البحر الاسود
للحبوب الغذائيه
في الثامن عشر من نوفمبر الجاري لرفع
تعليقها واستئناف في تطبيق
للامن الغذائيه العالميه
[موسيقى]
ادريس
مرحبا بك الى العربيه
المتحده والمسؤوله عن مبادره البحر الاسود
لقد نجحتم بالتعامل مع هواجس روسيا التي
طرحت اواخر شهر اكتوبر والتي ادت الى
تعليقي مشاركه الروسيه في المبادره لقد
نجحتم في اقناعها
باستئناف في المبادرات السابع عشر من
نوفمبر هل لنا ان نقلق من تكرار هذا
السيناريو في المستقبل
نوت طلال
علينا اولا ان نقر بالدور القيادي الذي
لعبته الامم المتحده والامين العام في هذه
الجهود
وبما اننا في
الشارع الدبلوماسي فهذا هو نفس المسار
الذي اتبعناه
وما اظهرناه للعالم هو ان التعدديه
والدبلوماسيه الهادئه بامكانها تحقيق
اشياء مهمه جدا لشعوب العالم الاكثر
احتياجا واعتقد بان هذا هو الدرس الاهم
الذي تعلمناه من مبادره البحر الاسود نحن
نفعل كل ذلك وكل هذا العمل يجري في خبر من
الحرب الجاريه فيجب ان اقول بان الناس
نتعرض للعديد من العقبات واشياء كثيره
ستحصل لاننا نحاول والمحافظه على استمرار
المبادره وتفعيلها خلال الحرب لذلك
بين اذربيج
علينا ان نتحلى بالسلوك المناسب وهذا ما
عبرت عنه الامم المتحده ولن تدخر جهدا
لانجاح المبادره
واستمرارها من
اجلي سكان العالم الاكثر احتياجا وفقرا
هذا كارتي اكبر طرفين في هذه المبادرات في
حاله حرب كما ان هنالك عقوبات غربيه
متزايده وليست متناقصه حدثنا قليلا عن
الصعوبات التي واجهت امها في تجديد او
بالاحرى استئناف هذه المباراه
اعتقد يا طلال بانها الصعوبه الرئيسيه
التي نواجهها هي مثلت الثقه والتقى شيء
يبنى ويتطلب الوقت من اجل بنائها والتقاء
موجوده في هذه اللحظه ليس لاننا قمنا بحل
كافه المشاكل بل لان هنالك الثقه باننا
سنبذل كل الجهد لتذليل ما تبقى من العقبات
التي لازمنا نواجهها وعلينا ان نحافظ على
هذه الثقه
ونحاول اشتراك كافه الشركاء الضروريين كل
الشركاء جنبا الى جنب لانجاح المبادره
لا تستطيع ان تقوم بهذا العمل لوحدها ان
نحن نلعب دورا الميسر في هذه المهمه ونحن
بحاجه المحافظه على الانتباه والمعلومات
الصحيحه وكافه المؤشرات حول كل ما يجري في
التجاره الدوليه همم
اه ازمه الغذائي والاسمده واسعارها والتي
تؤثر علينا جميعا وهذا بالفعل ما نقوم به
بينما نحاول بناء الجسور للوصول الى
الحلول المناسبه هل الامم المتحده ملتزمه
بضمان تدليلي او ازاله اي قيود في وجهه
صادرات روسيا من الحبوب والاسمده وفقا
لمذاكره التفاهم الموقعه بين روسيا والامم
المتحده نعم
حاسبين
في هذا المجال
واعتقد بان علينا الاعتراف بهذا التقدم
لكن كما قلت وكما ذكر الامين العام مرارا
لا تزال هنا لك معوقات وتحديات علينا
تجاوزها لقد كانت هنالك عقبات على الاثار
الثانويه للعقوبات وانت تعرف باننا نعمله
على انظمه العقوبات الثلاثه المختلفه في
امريكا وبريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبيه
ولذلك علينا معالجه المشاكل التي تواجهها
القطاع الخاص على وجه التحديد من اجل
الوصول الى المستوى المطلوب من اجل تجنبي
ازمه انعدام من غذائي في العالم
هل يمكن ان يتحقق ذلك من دون كسر العقوبات
الغربيه
من ذلك
القيود نعتقد بان الامر ممكن ولكن النوايا
الحسنه ضروريه وكذلك الالتزام والمشاركه
والقناعه بما جاء اهميه هذا الامر للعالم
لان هذه المساله لا تخص
العقوبات في حديثاتها بل تخص حل مشاكل
العالم النامي والشعوب العالم الاكثر
احتياجا يجب ان نحافظ على هذا الهدف
وهدفنا هو التخفيف معاناته الشعوب الاكثر
احتياجا في العالم
ومع ذلك علي ان اقول بان اسعار الغذاء لا
تزال مرتفعه وكذلك اسعار الازمه وهذا ما
يقلقنا لان هذه الاسعار تضرب المزارعين
الصغار في العالم فازمه تحمل الاسعار
نواجهها الان ستحول الى ازمه التوافر في
المستقبل اذا لم يتمكن المزارعون من
استخدام الاسمده همم من اجل الزراعه وهذه
هي المشكله الرئيسيه لقد التزمنا مع
روسيا الاتحاديه لتسهيل اصادراتهم من
المواد الغذائيه والا ده لان روسيا دوله
مهمه جدا في تجاره المواد الغذائيه
والاسمده ومن اجل حل هذه المشكله علينا ان
لا ندخل اوكرانيا في السوق الحكوميه فحسب
بل نحن بحاجه ايضا الى حبوب واسمده روس
الاتحاديه في السوق الحكوميه
هل لديكم مخاوف
فيما خصوص سلامه المرور السفن في البحر
الاسود والمراحل المختلفه من عمليه
التفتيش
سؤال مثير جدا عندما بدانا بهذه الجهود
وطرحنا
الالتزامات هي الاتفاق الكثيرون لم يؤمنوا
من اننا سنتمكن من تحقيق ذلك وثانيا من ان
سوف تكون امنه وقد اظهرنا للعالم
عبر عمل مركز التنسيق المشترك في اسطنبول
كان رائعا لم نواجه ولا حادثه واحده مع
السفن التي دخلت وخرجت
وبديكسي
البحر الاسود
وقمنا بتصدير اكثر من احد 10 مليون طن من
المواد الغذائيه من مرافع البحر الاسود
اعتقد باننا برهن بان المفهوم واسلوبي
تشغيلي هذه المبادره كان ناجحا ما هي
النسبه من 11 مليون
تصل الى الدول ذات داخل المتجني
لكن
فيما يخص القمح اغلبهم ذهب الى العالم
انمي وان لم اكن مخطئه اه بامكاني زملائي
تصحيح يعتقد بان الثلثاء هو ذهب الى الدول
ولكن كما يخص الذره
[موسيقى]
تستخدم كعلف حيواني وعلى الحيواني لم يذهب
الى الدول الناميه الى الدول الناميه
لديها اسلوب مختلف في استخدام العائله
الحيوان انه هو مقلب جدا كما تتخيل اللي
استيراد العلف الحيوانات
ذهب بشكل رئيسي الى العالم المتقدم
سمسم
والحبوب هي التي ذهبت الى الدول الناميه
الى اي حد مبادره البحر الاسود تساعد في
خفض اسعار الغذاء عالميه
كثيرا
اذا
اطلعنا الى مؤشر الغذاء العالميه
من انخفاض في
مؤشره اسعار الغذاء مع ذلك اسمح لي نحن
لسنا راضيين لاننا بحاجه الى تخفي الاسعار
بشكل اكبر
ولل الفقراء لكي يشعر
بفوائده
ومع ذلك
طبعا الموضه
البنك الدولي
بامكاننا ان نقول
بانه لولا حصول هذه المبادره فان 100
مليون شخص اضافي سيكونون فقره اليوم لان
اسعار الغذاء اساسيه
للقدرات الشرائيه الشهريه
فقد سهمت بشكل كبير لتجنب حتى المزيد من
الفقر في العديد من الدول اسمح لي نظيفه
شيئا طلال المشكله التي نواجهها
المانيا
تخفيض قيمتها لان الدولار قوي جدا
وكل ما زادت قوه الدولار
حتى في الدول زادت اسعار الغذاء
فالامر لا يخص تجاره فحسب بل كذلك الماليه
والشؤون الماليه الجزء المالي من ذلك ايضا
يؤثر على الاسعار في الدول الناميه
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده للتجاره والتنميه شكرا
جزيلا لكل هذه المعلومات
ونتمنى لك يوفر الحظ في مساعيك الانسانيه
المستقبليه شكرا
[موسيقى]